bonsoir à saint jean merci d'être avec
nous tairons qui déclare donc qu'il
respectera ses engagements de l'accord
sur le nucléaire à condition que les
états unis lèvent leurs sanctions
économiques
de son côté washington qui exige que
l'iran respecte le deal 2015 c'est un
dialogue de sourds oui et non parce que
si les deux acteurs souhaitent pas
revenir en fait à un accord toutefois
chacun d'eads était plutôt des trois
belligérants savoir les états unis
l'iran et l'union européenne
à chacun ses difficultés si du côté
américain on a plusieurs personnes au
sein de l'administration de biden comme
jacques ceux d'ivan robert mallet qui
ont participé dans les négociations du
jce ipo et font désormais partie donc de
l'administration de biden
toutefois il est nécessaire donc il ya
plusieurs difficultés côté américain à
savoir réintégrer l'accord est aussi
convaincre les autres partisans comme
par exemple notamment donc les
républicains qui étaient réticents donc
après l'administration obama et le mark
était comme en tant que ce qu'on appelle
by participe à grimentz
c'est à dire que c'est un accord bi
partisan vous qui permettrait à la corde
être dans d'être donc durable dans le
temps que des iraniens
si donc il ya une impérativité
l'impératif de parvenir à un accord pour
l'administration de fanni toutefois il y
à des pressions qui sont en interne mais
il allait il ya un impératif de de
parvenir à l'accord notamment afin avant
les élections prochaines iranienne de du
21 juin à fin juin 2021 côté européen
les l'ensemble des belligérants donc
savoir la france à l'angleterre
l'angleterre à l'allemagne ils sont un
peu entre les deux voies ces trois
nations n'ont pas pu donc instaurer un
mécanisme qui permettrait de temps dure
la peau de l'accord notamment donc
travers les mécanismes commerciaux
dienst ex qui n'ont pas permis en fait à
l'iran de survivre lors des quatre
années 30 mais d'un autre côté c'est
nation l'un sont en train de conserves
de prendre connaissance
que le jce purée à vendre durant
l'administration obama n'est pas le même
et qui font tenir compte d'un ensemble
de changements qui sont dans le contexte
géopolitique notamment donc l'apparition
de plusieurs de nouveaux axes comme
l'axé israélo émirati ou encore le fait
de comprendre les craintes des dépit
sand et des autres nations de la région
les etats unis les européens la chine et
la russie veulent tout en la vie pour va
tout faire pour faire sauver l'accord la
russie a de bonnes relations avec l'iran
à ce qu'elle peut servir de médiateur
dans ce dossier selon vous ce soir la
russie et la chine je pense que les deux
nations ont des cartes pour jouer donc
l'intermédiaire entre guillemets lawn
est procureur com quels termes qui
employait le plus souvent par notamment
par le président macron notamment à
cause des différents accords conclus
entre les deux pays et les intérêts
stratégiques qui les unissent notamment
en syrie et en irak
donc je pense que la russie pourrait
jouer ce rôle puisque les européens en
ce moment alors enjoint des élections
présidentielles vont avoir lieu en iran
pour élire le successeur de roy ni est
ce que ça peut changer la donne si un
accord est parvenu les réformistes au
ronde donc l'aider les réformistes
auront de quoi marquer tu es leur
prochaine la prochaine élection à savoir
le fait de dialoguer avec les oxydants
autres autrement on doit par l'on doit
s'attendre à un président qui est du
côté dont étaient des conservateurs
alors une levée des sanctions
américaines sur l'économie iranienne
pourrait permettre à au camp modéré en
tout cas d'être d'accéder au pouvoir
n'est ce pas aussi dans l'intérêt
finalement des états unis que de lever
ses sanctions
exactement parce que le fait d'avoir un
conservateur en face style monsieur
raïssi ou encore monsieur ghalibaf qui
est encore la tête de la mairie terran
qui pour certains est l'étape pour
parvenir à la présidence pourrait rendre
le dialogue
un peu plus difficile et donc durer
encore un peu plus de temps toutefois on
regarde et donc le côté positif on ne
peut pas nier qui est actuellement à des
négociations secrètes entre les deux
nations
soit de manière directe dans une course
dans un tir ce pays comme ça c'était le
cas à oman avant que l'administration
obama d'après ne puisse réussir des
élections est actuellement on a
plusieurs candidats qui peuvent servir
d'intermédiaire comme par exemple le
sultanat d'oman qui l'a déjà fait le
collègue qui l'a déjà proposé ou encore
la diplomatie qatarie qui qui est qui
est en train de monter en grade de
reprendre de l'activité notamment après
donc l' annonce de la fin de la crise du
du golfe merci sam hamad est d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france